I Love 静岡
はいというわけで、久しぶりに茶畑にやってきたんですけども
今日は僕の特技か何だかよくわかんないんですけど
多分皆さんにはない能力が多分僕にはあるんですよ
ちょっとそれがなにかといいますとちょっと今そっちに太陽があります
でもねぇこれがねぇもぅ特技かどうかもよくわかんないんですけども
ちょっと太陽見ますね、いきますよ
どうだい、太陽を見ると必ずくしゃみが出ます
これはなんなんだろう、太陽アレルギー？ちょっとわかんないんですけど、なんか太陽を見るとくしゃみが出るんすよ
はい、というわけで今回の動画は、あのちょっと嘘だと思ってる人いると思うんすよ
ほんとに出るんすよ、ちょ、も一回やってみ…あげるよ
どうだい、いや別にかっこつけることじゃねーな
俺はマジな方で太陽を見るとくしゃみが出ちまうんだ
で、今回はですね、まずなんで出るんだろう。太陽アレルギーとか？
ちょ、わかんないんですけど、ちょっとまずみんなが出るかどうかもわかんないんですけど
僕出ます、太陽見るとくしゃみがね。いや僕の友達とかはみんな出ないって言ってたから
僕だけのなんか特技かなと思ってるわけですよ
まぁ、なにかよくわかんないんですけど、ちょ、今日はですね
この太陽を見てくしゃみが出る特技を生かして何連続くしゃみができるか実験してみようと思います
太陽の力を借りて、今日はちょっと僕のくしゃみの限界に迫ってみようと思います。では行こう！
で、ちょ、ルールとしては、てかもう今日の動画くしゃみとかより景色を楽しんでくれ
この広大な茶畑、最高じゃないすか！
よし、行きます行きます。よーいスタート
こんにちは～
リベンジです
あ～、ちょ調子悪いなぁ。連続性がないのかなぁ
連続性はないのかもしれない
ちょ調子ワリィなぁ
ちょっと調子が悪いので休憩です
なんでだろうなぁ、いつもだとめっちゃでるんですけど
いやでもほんとに出るのは分かったっしょ。出ますからね、太陽の申し子なのかもしれない
ちょ、くしゃみでるの待ちましょう。そのうち出ると思うんで
やべえなぁ
くしゃみがでねぇ。何が原因なんだ、わからない、太陽もそんなに弱くないとは思うんですよ
よっしゃ、本気出します。もっと自分に素直になろう。俺は出る俺は出る。俺はくしゃみ出せる
よし、いけるぞいけるぞ、戻ってきた感覚が戻ってきた。太陽が強くなってきた
よーしよしよしよし、来たぞ来たぞ。来たぞみんな！みんな来たぞ。太陽エネルギー来た！
これさぁ
俺周りから見たらマジでやばい人だぜ
太陽を見てこんな顔してずっとカメラ回してんだよ
もうちょっとがんばっていきましょう。まだいけるぞ
心臓痛くなってきた
先生もう限界っす、心臓が破裂しそう
終了！はいというわけでお分かりいただけましたでしょうか。
これねぇみんなできるかわかんないんだけど、ちょっと太陽の力をエネルギーに変えてるんすよ
出そうと
いつでも出せますよ
という僕の特技自慢でした。茶畑っていいよね